始め戦闘スタンプー
ふわぁ
入って夕食ですねなんと大会スタンプにはじめシャツを僕のスタンプがいよいよ
スタートしました
いろんな方々爪切お礼スタンプ出さないのだして出していって本当にいろんな音校
ありがたい声を頂いてねなかなか時間がかかりましたけどなんとが出来ました
ありがとうございます
外サーブをイラストを交えてくれたのがコレ
の高校の後輩の子ねほんとにちょっと忙しいと思ったんですけど本当にありがとう
ございますで line のスタンプショップで
ウェーブ方肇社長って検索したら普通に食べスタッフが出ると思うので是非
使ってみてくださいでしょうね者も自分のスタンプがコーデている
みんながそれを使って会話するっていうのはね
考え深いものがあります
じゃあちょっと実際に見てみましょう運び普通に何を開いて育ったの
スタンプショップ
の
ドネルどこのクレイザーがスタンプですね
あったん
これでございますコントフリースって種類がでちょっとこういう感じで色々あるんです
けども
色以外とねー難しかったんですねそのどれが使いやすいかなとかどんなのが幸あれなん
だなーとか思いつつ一応40種類準備してあります
スタンにおいらのススメがこちらの遺体シリーズです頭痛い女インター指痛いお腹痛い
足痛い心痛いその2台シリーズをうまく使ってまぁいろんなイベントとか大事なことと
かね
いろんな用事をサボってほしいそれが俺の願いです実際に使ってみましょう
とび感と防犯しようって話してるんですよもう何をしようって花
頭を捨てて例えばこういう盤面があります防犯したい人ビクトリア湖使える使え
るっていう
ちょっと待って
ちょっと待ってと言っていますもう版したいけどもう版したいけれども
頭痛い名たい指たいお腹痛い足痛い
心いたいってね
連続興行に腰掛けるわけです頭痛いメーター指痛いお腹痛い足で心痛い
こうやってねこうイベントを完全に消し去ることができますこう
約束事ね完全復興しますそれここで彼がどう帰ってくるかですね
てかよく見た筈井くんのスタンプですっ
そこでスカイこういう使い方もできます背景でこれ以外にもいろんなスタンプを準備さ
せていただきました高
とても満足いくものができたと思っておりますぜひね外れ社長らりすタップ
使ってみて良い
てはいかがでしょうかじゃーん